la maison pavillon
apparu dans les années 1730 et modèle le
plus répandu au xviiie siècle la maison
pavillon se perpétue partout dans l'île
jusqu'à nos jours
parmi ses principales caractéristiques
le traitement de façade
elles peuvent comporter une porte
flanqué de deux fenêtres de portes trois
portes trois portes et de fenêtres
toutes ses variantes forme le modèle de
base de la maison créole traditionnel
ce type de maison se perpétue au dix
neuvième siècle notamment dans les
bourgs ruraux du sud de l'île on en voit
encore de très beaux exemples notamment
à l'antre-2
la toiture à quatre pans ou toitures à
la française est également
caractéristique des maisons pavillon
tout comme leur plan rectangulaire au
carré appelé plan masse et
ce type d'habitat s'inspire de modèles
européens et plus particulièrement des
maisons rurales française des xviie et
xviiie siècles ces gros cubes en bois
présentent souvent un aspect rustique
correspondant à la réalité d'une société
profondément rurale celle du nil
qualifié de grenier des mascareignes par
le gouverneur mailles de la bourdonnais
autre héritage du xviiie l'est var ont
inspiré d architecture coloniale
portugaise et franco pondichéry elle les
premières varangue réunionnaise comme
celle de la maison grand cours à saint
pol ou celle de la cure de saint denis
sont appelés varangue sous combles car
elle se trouve sous la toiture
principale de la maison
va ranger maison pavillons sont des
références incontournables de
l'architecturé créole traditionnels